Picture your entire life laid out in
weeks. If you live to 80, you have
roughly 4,000 weeks total. That's it. If
you're 25, you've already spent 1,300
weeks gone. At 35, nearly halfway
through. Here's what hits different.
You'll spend 13 years just looking at
screens. That's 676 weeks staring at
pixels. Another third sleeping. two
years in meetings that could have been
emails. Most weeks blend together
because we're not actually living them.
We're existing through them, waiting for
someday. But here's the thing about
someday. It's not on the calendar. Your
phone, 11 years of your life, that's 572
weeks gone. The question isn't how much
time you have left. It's what are you
building with the time you have.